Hello, Adrian.
What's up, Ash?
Hey.
Little while.
But.
Long time no see.
How are you?
I'm doing absolutely great, you tell.
So, yeah, things going well here, so...
It's been six months, I guess, yeah, that we last spoke.
Ohh.
If I've been in those that long, it's I guess so.
Bye.
Yep, it is.
So Kip had some family issues because of which he had to travel to his hometown. And so fortunately, I had worked with you in the past, so I thought of, okay, let's get on the call with Adrian, talk to him and get to know how things are moving.
Yeah.
Okay, so I hope Kip is doing a decent job in terms of things and managing the team and performance side of things.
Hoh.
Yeah, Kip's doing a great job. The new guys, Grayson and Abner, they're taking a little bit longer to come up to speed than, you know, some of the other, you know, like Santino and Shiraz, but I think that a lot of that was to do with Sterling, who had been on our account for
I.
Right.
at that point and really helped kind of speed them up where
It's just taking a little bit longer for the two new guys to really come up to speed.
Really get, really get rock'n'roll where they need to be.
Yep, and obviously they have support from you as well, in case they stuck anywhere process-wise, and Santino is also there to support them, and we also have Shiraj on the team. We have Sterling as well with some different partners, so I think it spoke with Sterling some time back, right?
Yep.
Yeah, I think it might have been one of the last two. I had to cancel last week because we had an emergency come up. I think the week before that, when I was talking with Kip, Sterling was, I think, Kip and Sterling sit next to each other and I talked to Sterling for a couple of minutes and that was nice because I had
Yeah.
I ran out of time to check in with him on Sterling's last day, so it was good to talk with him for a couple minutes.
Yeah, yeah, it is. So this is the benefit of having a close-knit team. Even if they are not working with you, they were off-boarded, you can still reach out to them, talk to them, and know how they are doing.
And, of course.
Yeah.
All right, and before I start off, thank you so much, Adrian, for approving the new request for ADMIN. So I think he had some medical concerns because of which he had to rush. I'll let you know about status for tomorrow. Most likely he'll be in, but still if in case anything goes out, I'll update you timely.
Kip.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Any new developments since Kip has started in terms of new clients, new business?
Well, I mean, we're rolling through, we're about 75% complete on a new email filtering migration, so we'll be finishing that up probably mid to late July.
Got a new backup solution that the guys have been installing and migrating clients over from the old ones. That's really about it. It's just more of the same.
So...
Right, that's good.
Thank you so much for sharing that. And as we have already said, our engineers are doing a good job and Shiraj was afforded in the end of May. So he'll be looking for other opportunities. Before I jump into the presentation deck, any feedback?
Yep.
that you want to share for the engineers that I need to work on.
Nope, nope, just, I mean, it's we're just slow, we're getting them up to speed, just taking a little bit longer for these guys. So, I mean, other than, I mean, the work they're doing is quality work, it's just need to get need to get more out of them.
Great. And I believe the utilization target for Abner and Grayson, it's less than as compared to Centino because they are relatively new and as they pick the pace, they would gradually climb on.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's correct.
Okay.
With that being said, I'll quickly go ahead and share my screen.
I'll start off with there.
Yeah, just give me a second.
Let me know, Adrian, if you are able to see my screen.
I can see it.
Thank you. So this is the utilization trend for Santino, starting with 1st June until June 5th, where he had been 75% and above when most of the day that is just June 2nd, where he was 65%, which reduced his overall average to 71%.
But other than that, he was able to surpass the required utilization target on 1st, 3rd, 4th, and 5th.
Great.
Next is the tickets closure for him, where he closed 56 tickets out of 79, making his utilization closure target at 71%. The kind of tickets that he worked on, they were belong to, they belong to file restore, health check.
agent installations, cleanup, and endpoints backup. So yeah, as the time would progress, he will probably get a different type of alerts to work on so that he can expand his knowledge, at the same time work on the utilization of these tools.
Yep.
Any questions there?
Nope.
Kip.
Next is Jason. So his utilization available had been 34 percent. So this is what he is expected to deliver as of yet, but he is working towards making it to 40, 50, 60, and then 75. So Adrian, by when we are expecting them to reach 75 percent.
I'd say somewhere between probably like the 60-90 days of them being on the count.
Okay.
All right, so that's gonna happen somewhere in July.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you so much. Next is the tickets closure for Grayson with 54% error rate where he worked on agent missing alerts, disk space and health check alerts.
Similarly for Abner, here the utilization had been 34% throughout the week. And the closure rate is at 42%, with him working on patch policy alerts, agent missing services alerts, and backup.
Kip.
John.
These were the numbers from the last week. Way forward, so we have board reviews that is that will continue to be there until we are sure that engineers are doing a good job. And yeah, that's about it. Bill Lighty, I think Kip has discussed with you already, so I'm going to skip this one.
And that is it.
Cool.
Great, just like old days.
Just like the old days. Yeah. Well, I mean, things are going, things are going okay. I mean, good. I mean, it's the questions that Grayson and Abner are asking. I mean, they're good questions and they don't usually ask the question more than once. So I'm happy with that.
Sing.
Yep, just continue to build them up and get them to where we want them or need them to be. I think that's just going to be the next thing that we work through.
Hello.
I appreciate that, Adrian. Thank you so much for your help and support throughout. And I will convey this feedback to the Engineering Store, which will help them to do better. And so like I said, we have our call cadence as weekly. Next is going to be on June 18th. If Kip is in, you will drive it.
Kip.
If he's not in, then I'll be your guy on the date.
I think we skipped or we, I'm going to be on PTO on the 18th, so we were going to skip that one.
Alright, so it will be 25th of June then, right?
Yep, that sounds right.
Okay.
Thank you so much for the update. I'll quickly go ahead and update the right so that we have.
population there.
All right. Well, I guess this is it for today. I appreciate your time and patience, Adrian. Thank you so much for being a wonderful partner. And we're looking forward to have this partnership for a longer time. And yeah, I appreciate it. Thanks A lot.
Fantastic. Thanks, Ashish. Have a great day.
You too. Bye.
Right.